il n'y a rien de plus insupportable
qu'avoir un mec en promo qui est là
assis sur son siège qui l'a vu on va le
faire avec toi tu couches avec qui en ce
moment
jumelles Julie Gayet encore elle
décidément comprenez-vous ces stars qui
souhaitent garder leur vie privée qui
refuse de toute interview c'est l'acteur
Benoît Magimel qui est revenu sur son
rapport au journaliste à la presse
people il a déclaré de jeunes pour
France Inter être le cauchemar des
journalistes regardez mais c'est vrai
que j'ai été catalogué cauchemars des
journalistes prince du silence quoi
parce qu'à chaque fois on posait des
questions ça me regarde pas
ce soir
j'ai envie de garder sa vie privée mais
il a travaillé toute
dans les contrats de cinéma il y a
marqué que tu te dois de faire la promo
mais faire la promo ça veut pas dire tu
vas la promener du film ça te dit pas
quel âge a ton fils avec qui tu couches
mais rien de plus insupportable qu'avoir
un mec en promo qui est là assis sur son
siège qui veut rien dire qu'il tire la
tronche et qui est comme ça
publique on veut savoir tu vois c'est
différent quand même tout d'un coup
ouais ouais ouais ouais Mathieu oui
pourquoi tu mets un poster d'une star
dans ta chambre c'est pas juste parce
que c'est un bon acteur c'est aussi
parce que c'est quelqu'un que tu te
rends Florent bébé comment tu peux dire
une telle bêtise c'est la vérité mais
non mais non une star c'est comme le
sexe c'est l'inconnu c'est 50% du
plaisir
il faut jamais rencontrer ses idoles au
contraire pourquoi jenny est une star tu
sais pas où il habite tu sais pas quoi
livrer tu sais pas ce qu'elle mange tu
sais rien Jean-Michel Jarre elle a eu
plein de polémiques sur le dos
Farmer Mylène Farmer aussi où elle
habite et c'est tout et bah oui mais il
y a eu plein de rumeurs il y a eu plein
de choses qu'elle a un peu alimenté
aussi
Claude François personne n'y croyait en
même temps il y a eu deux phénomènes il
avait l'habitude de mettre sa vie privée
et ses accidents qu'il avait eu tout le
long de sa carrière en lumière ce soit
quand on lui a tiré dessus en 77 quand
il allait à Bondues en 75 quand il y a
une action de voiture etc donc tout le
monde est habitué on dit ça y est il a
monté un coup il a dit qu'il était mort
tout le monde a pensé ça alors il était
pas une heure pas du tout non non il
était chez lui il s'est élevé à 13h j'ai
le détail précis du rapport de police ah
oui il était rentré la veille de Leysin
à 13h il se réveille il téléphone à son
chauffeur il appelle il donne des
consignes il y avait son attaché de
presse qui était là Marie-Thérèse à
l'époque et puis Kathleen sa fiancé et
puis il leur prépare un petit déjeuner
c'est-à-dire de la purée d'avocat sur
des toasts
et un moment donné et à 14h10 il rentre
dans la salle de bain il dit je prends
une douche parce qu'il avait pris un peu
les rayons du soleil et c'était mis un
peu nul solaire je vais enlever ça il
prend simplement une douche et un moment
donné il voit l'applique qui a dévié de
un centimètres elle applique en cuivre
et là et chaque fois qu'il rentrait dans
sa douche il voyait cette applique il
faisait un petit geste avec deux doigts
pour la dresser parce qu'il était très
maniaque très précis et c'est le souci
du détail qui l'a tué
une fois de trop il l'a fait une fois de
trop il est resté collé à l'applique
évidemment il a fait ce qu'il ne faut
jamais faire quand on prend le courant
c'est à dire qu'on met l'autre main pour
se dégager ce qui fait qu'on fait un
circuit fermé à partir de là c'est foutu
incroyable donc c'est sa fiancée
Kathleen qui l'a attrapé heureusement
souvent quand il y a un électrocuté il y
en a deux parce que un autre cours pour
le défendre et on prend aussi le courant
d'accord comme elle était isolée des
sabots de bois elle a arraché et elle a
été sauvée grâce à ça elle a elle a elle
a allongé dans le couloir les pompiers
sont arrivés très très vite seulement
les ceux du c'est le 15e qui est arrivé
pas le 16e ils étaient sur un incendie
ah non c'est très compliqué il y a tout
un tas d'éléments neuvième étage les
pompiers montent les étagères ils ont
tenté toutes les réanimations et il est
possible et un moment donné à
14h45 précis es c'était fini
Elise lucer répondent aux gens qui la
disent agressives à l'occasion du 10ème
anniversaire de cash investigation pour
ce programme de France 2 à la donner une
interview à Telestar et a dit les
équipes avec lesquelles je travaille
savent très bien que je ne suis pas
froides pugnéas oui mais à tavius
doivent être carré on le doit à noter
les spectateurs cache investigation est
une émission qui gratte ça ne peut pas
plaire à tout le monde donc elle pense
qu'elle joue à véritable rôle elle dit
les gens de plus m'appeler parce qu'ils
sont persuadés que quand il m'appelle
j'enregistre tout je voudrais savoir ce
que vous en pensez parce qu'aujourd'hui
et on est en train de remettre un petit
peu sa manière de travailler en doute on
dit que c'est le métier d'un peu de
voyou on dit quelle pièce les gens et
que en gros c'est comme quand tu
cherches un téléphone quand tu cherches
tu trouves qu'est-ce que tu en penses à
mytho je déteste cette émission là
pourquoi toujours dit parce que c'est
une émission ils ont un a priori avant
de faire l'émission ils disent bon on va
faire je sais pas de quel sujet
Coca-Cola les piles sont dangereux
n'importe quoi voilà et ben ils vont
faire tout leur documentaire pour
arriver à cette conclusion il change pas
d'avis en cours de route un témoignage
qui sera décharge GE pour le truc ils
vont écarter pour que ça soit uniquement
quelque chose bien sûr que oui
ce que tu dis est partiellement vrai à
savoir que oui ils auront une idée de
départ mais il leur arrive de moduler
quand même sur plein de points quand il
se rendent compte qu'ils se sont plantes
qui se sont trompés ils ont toujours
raison
ce jour celui qui n'a jamais eu sa
langue dans sa poche n'a pas hésité à
soutenir Pierre Palmade le lynchage
médiatique on lèche on lâche et on lâche
on lâche c'est pas à moi le juger il est
à toi il y a des procès il y a des juges
il y a des toute la machine judiciaire
pour ça je ne le défends pas parce que
c'est pas descendable tout simplement
simplement je dis est-ce qu'on peut
mettre un [__] douce est-ce qu'on peut
parler d'autre chose et arrêtons la
double peine la triple peine
je trouve que il a déjà la tête assez
sous l'eau comme c'est dit qu'on le la
peine de continuer donc tu dis que tout
le monde ne lâche oui enfin on le lâche
mais parce qu'il n'est pas défendable
c'est le contraire je n'ai jamais
défendu on peut pas défendre ça c'est
pas possible j'ai posé la question des
victimes qui souffrent en ce moment
lui-même il y a tout le monde qui
s'ouvre il y a beaucoup de souffrance
là-dessus c'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter avec le tribunal populaire ils
sont déjà condamnés avec tout ce qu'on
dit tout ce qu'on dit à la télévision la
radio ils sont déjà condamnés par le le
tribunal populaire il y a des juges pour
ça il y a des flics il y a des
magistrats ils vont avoir
le procès qu'il faut et tout le monde
pourra avoir son avis là-dessus nous on
ne connaît pas le dossier je connais pas
le dossier tu connais toi moi je le
connais pas non et ça c'est tout que
tout le monde en fasse des tonnes les
BFM voilà moi je dis est-ce qu'on peut
mettre la [__] un peu douce et est-ce
qu'on peut parler d'autre chose un petit
peu c'est tout